now that we know a little bit about the
imaginary unit i let's see if we can if
we can simplify more involved
expressions like this one right over
here two plus three i plus seven i
squared plus five i to the third power
plus nine i to the fourth power and i
encourage you to pause the video right
now and try to simplify this on your own
so as you can see here we have various
powers of i you could view this as i to
the first power we have i squared here
and we already know that i squared
i squared is defined to be negative one
then we have i to the third power
i to the third power would just be i
times this or negative i and we already
reviewed this when we first introduced
the imaginary unit i but i'll do it
again i to the fourth power is just
going to be i times this which is the
same thing as negative 1 times i that's
i to the third power times i again
i times i is negative 1 so that's
negative 1 times negative 1 which is
equal to 1 again
so we can rewrite this whole thing
we could rewrite it as 2
plus
i
7 i squared is going to be the same
thing
so
i squared is negative 1. so this is the
same thing as 7
times negative 1. so that's just going
to be
minus 7
and then we have 5i to the third power i
to the third power is negative i
so this could be rewritten as negative i
so this term right over here we could
write as
minus
i or negative 5i depending on how you
want to think about it and then finally
i to the fourth power i to the fourth
power is just one so this is just equal
to one so this whole term just
simplifies to
nine so how could we simplify this more
well we have several
terms that that are not not imaginary
that they are real numbers for example
we have
this 2 is a real number
negative 7 is a real number and nine is
a real number
so we could just add those up so two
plus negative seven would be negative
five
negative five plus nine would be four so
the real numbers add up to
and now we have these imaginary numbers
so 3 times i
minus 5 times i
so if you have 3 of something and then i
were to subtract 5 of something of that
same something from it now you're going
to have negative 2 of that something so
or another way of thinking about it is
the coefficients 3 minus 5 is negative
2. so 3 i's minus 5 i's that's going to
give you negative 2 i
now you might say well can we simplify
this any further
well no you really can't this right over
here this right over here is
a real number 4 is a number that we've
been dealing with throughout our
mathematical careers
and negative 2i
negative 2i that's an imaginary number
imaginary number
and so what we really consider this is
this this 4 minus 2i this is we can now
consider this entire expression to
really be a number
so this is a number that has a real part
and an imaginary part and numbers like
this we call complex numbers
com
it is a complex
it is a complex number why is it complex
well it has a real part and an imaginary
part
and you might say well you know gee well
it wouldn't can't any real number be
considered a complex number for example
if i have the real number if i have the
real number 3 can't i just write the
real number 3 is 3 plus
i
and you would be correct this any real
number is a complex number you could
view this you could view this right over
here as a complex number and actually
the real numbers are a subset of the
complex numbers likewise imaginary
numbers are a subset of the complex
numbers for example you could rewrite i
as
a real part 0 is a real number
plus
plus i
so the imaginaries are subset of complex
numbers real numbers are a subset of
complex numbers and then complex numbers
also have all of the the the sums and
differences or all the numbers that have
both real and imaginary parts